in our series on the financial fallout
from the coronavirus we're looking at
the economic pain and how to get America
back to work
this graph shows just how bad job losses
are compared to the last 50 years it's
expected to get worse as layoffs
continue Gary Cohn is president Trump's
former chief economic adviser and
director of the National Economic
Council he also served as president and
chief operating officer of Goldman Sachs
including during the last recession good
morning thank you for being with us
thanks for having me everything a you
Gary as you as you we as we just said
the president wants to get the country
up and going by the end of the month
health experts some of them are saying
this may be premature if you were still
running goldman sachs at this point
would you be comfortable sending your
employees back in a couple of weeks so
anthony remember the ultimate decision
to reopen businesses are the businesses
themselves they're the ones they shut
down first and businesses are
responsible for two people they're
responsible for their employees but
they're equally responsible for their
clients and their customers if I were
still in private business running a
large organization I would be working on
a very detailed plan to open up in some
way but in a highly segmented faction
fraction I I would have my employees
separate in location and I have them
very segregated in times when they came
to work and I would keep those those
different groups separate so if I had a
group that came in on Monday morning
they would never see the group that came
in on Tuesday morning and the Monday
morning group might come back in on
Wednesday morning so you really have to
think through a highly disciplined way
to bring your employees back to work so
you're thinking of this as a very slow
and deliberate process over how long a
period of time would you think well
we're gonna have to respond based on a
reinfection rate if we see no
reinfection we can speed up the process
if we see
affection come back into the system will
probably slow down the process so we're
gonna have to take our clues from the
disease itself covert 19 is gonna be the
answer well Geary's you know nearly 17
million people have filed for
unemployment claims today's numbers will
add to that tally so what do you think
success looks like a pro probe
coronavirus what what are we going to be
dealing with so so Gail look the
American population has done a very good
job listening to the government and
staying at home and removing themselves
from the workforce and removing
themselves from the economy that's been
very important to flatten the curve and
we've had better results than we once
forecasted but that's really good now we
have to think about restarting our
economy but not restarting the infection
cycle and and that's important so I
think a successful return would be very
methodically bringing Pat people back
into the workforce in smaller groups and
seeing what happens making sure people
don't become reinfected and if we have a
reinfection rate slowing that back down
or stopping the re-emergence into the
economy the worst thing that could
happen would be for us to throw everyone
back into the economic cycle and have to
go back to having 97% of our people
being told to stay home again we're much
better off to go through this slowly
than to go through it quickly than
happen to have to stop again you know
those stimulus checks are allegedly
going to have Donald Trump's name on
them the word is it's being reported
that it's going to delay the checks the
White House of course denies that but do
you think it's a good look for the
president to have his name on the check
and there is a $1,200 check enough so
again what is important is the payroll
protection plan the payroll protection
plan that Congress put in place was a
very very important plan this was a plan
put in place to make sure that
hardworking Americans received a
paycheck received the Paycheck that they
deserve they deserve that paycheck
because they
were told as good citizens of his
country do not go to work and the
businesses that they work for were
forced to shut down and the government
wisely has said look instead of going on
unemployment stay attached to your
business and we're gonna send you a
paycheck
as you were working so you can support
your family you can buy your groceries
you can buy the your other essential
goods that you need that's what's
important that program unfortunately is
running out of money or may have run out
of money last night it's imperative that
Congress come back and replenish that
program Gary you're saying we basically
we can't throw enough money at this
situation in some respects we can in
some respect the mistake would be to not
throw money at the program we will have
plenty of time to figure out how to get
pay for this and get the money out of
the system but telling people to stay
home and not giving them the amount of
money they need to support their family
buy their groceries buy their essentials
and pay their rent would be a
catastrophic mistake and forcing
everyone on unemployment would also be a
bad mistake we need people to stay
attached to the companies that they were
working at prior to the Kovach crisis so
they stay attached and they know once we
start going back to work they'll be in
touch with their employer their employer
will be able to tell them hey you're
coming back to work on this day and we
won't have to go through a rehiring
cycle once we're trying to reopen the
economy all right Gary Cohen thank you
so much for being with us